In this video, we'll look at a number of
different issues that you may have to
troubleshoot inside of Microsoft
Windows. In fact, this type of message
is a very common one that you might have
to deal with. This is, of course, the
blue screen of death. This may be
related to bad hardware. It might have
bad drivers. There might be an issue
with the application that you're using.
But something inside of your system has
determined that whatever error has
occurred prevents the entire operating
system from continuing. And because of
that, it's going to put a message on our
screen that tells us that Windows has to
stop what it's doing. And then it gives
us some information that might help us
with the troubleshooting process. In
previous Windows versions, you got a
very detailed set of information that
was provided on what we call the Windows
blue screen of death. On newer versions
of Windows, we get a prettier stop
screen, but the issue is still the same.
Our operating system stops completely
and we have to reboot our system to get
the system back up and running again. If
you find that your system will not
reboot after this Windows stop error,
then you might want to try the last
known good option inside of the startup
screen, there might be an option for
system restore that you can use, or you
may have to roll back a driver if this
is related to a driver that you have
recently installed. Another good option
would be to try to use safe mode in
order to resolve any problems that are
occurring during a normal startup. If
you believe the problem may be related
to hardware, this might be a good
opportunity to take the top off of your
computer and try removing and replacing
all of the different components to
ensure that you have a good connection.
And if you're not sure if the problem is
related to hardware or software, you
might want to perform a hardware
diagnostics. This will test your CPU,
your memory, and other components within
your system, and you may be able to rule
out hardware as the cause of this issue.
On this Windows error stop screen or
this blue screen of death as we like to
call it, it provides us with information
that we can use for the troubleshooting
process. For example, it tells us for
more information about this issue and
possible fixes, visit windows.com/stop
code. And they put a QR code on the
screen. You can try this QR code
yourself. It will take you over to the
Microsoft support website. They also
give you information about the error
itself. This stop code is kernel mode
heap corruption. And you can type this
into the Windows support site to get
options for troubleshooting the hardware
or the software of your system.
But perhaps our issue is not a blue
screen type issue, but the operating
system itself is not performing
efficiently. Maybe it's running
sluggishly or you're finding that it
slows down and speeds up. You might want
to look at your task manager to see what
applications are running and to see if
any of those applications are using an
excessive number of resources. For
example, task manager can show you how
much CPU, memory, disk access, and
network access is being used by each
individual application. You can also
click the performance tab and get an
overview of how these individual
resources have been performing over the
last 60 seconds. This is a great
short-term view of how your system is
performing, and you may be able to
visually see where the different spikes
are occurring with the different
resources inside of your computer. The
problem you're having might be related
to a known bug in the operating system,
which may have already been resolved.
So, you might want to check Windows
Update to ensure that you have the
latest patches and latest fixes for your
OS. Most operating systems need to have
some free disk space that they can use
for the normal operation of the OS. So,
you might want to check the availability
of disk space on your computer. If
you're running out of space, you might
want to free up some space for the OS to
use. And if you're running a hard drive,
you might want to run a def frag just to
get that much more efficiency out of
your storage device. If you're on a
laptop, you may notice that the laptop
slows down if you're not directly
connected to a power source. This is a
normal configuration for most laptops
and it's designed for efficient use of
your CPU and to limit the amount of heat
that's created inside of your laptop. If
you're not sure if this throttling is
your problem, you might want to connect
it to a power source and monitor the CPU
usage when you're connected to direct
power. And it's possible that this
sluggish behavior may be caused by virus
or malware. So, you might want to update
your anti virus signatures, run a scan,
and make sure that your system doesn't
have anything running that you don't
know about.
Some of the messages that you do not
want to see when you're starting your
computer are operating system not found
or missing operating system. This is
obviously a problem because your system
can't identify where your operating
system might be. So, obviously, it will
not be able to start the OS. You might
also have problems if you try to install
a separate operating system at the same
time for dual boot purposes. You might
find that the boot loader itself has
been replaced or changed, preventing the
original operating system from starting.
If your operating system is not found
during startup, it could be that you've
plugged in a bootable drive that no
longer has an operating system on it.
So, you simply need to remove that media
from your system and try restarting
again. Windows also includes a
troubleshooting feature known as startup
repair. It will go through the most
common issues associated with startup
and try resolving them automatically.
And if your problem is related to a
bootloader or you may have changed the
location where Windows may be installed,
you might want to change the Windows
boot configuration database or the BCD.
In earlier versions of Windows, we
referred to this as the boot.ini file.
Now, it uses a different process that
allows you to change this boot
configuration database so that you can
add different startup parameters to the
Windows operating system. So, if you'd
like to resolve any problems with the
boot configuration database, you can use
the bootrec command. And if you use it
with the /rebuild bcd option, it will
rebuild the Windows boot configuration
database from the recovery console
command prompt. If you run this in the
recovery console, it will scan all of
your drives to find a Windows
installation. If it finds one, it will
tell you where it's found that
installation, and you can choose to add
that installation to your boot list and
then restart your computer.
Startup repair is a utility that can
find and solve many different problems
automatically. For example, if you have
changed a Windows boot loader, you might
be getting a message on your screen like
missing NT loader or a similar message.
You can run startup repair. it will look
for that missing Windows configuration
and add it back to your existing
bootloadader. If you've changed your
Windows directory name or you've moved
it to a different drive, you can have
Windows startup repair find that Windows
configuration or as we've already seen,
you can manually configure the boot
configuration database yourself. And
sometimes you'll start up Windows and it
will automatically start into safe mode
instead of starting into the normal
Windows configuration. If that's the
case, you can run starter prepare to try
to determine why your system is only
booting in safe mode instead of the
normal Windows config.
Sometimes your Windows operating system
is working as expected, but there's one
piece of hardware that for some reason
is not working inside of Windows. It may
be that the device is not starting at
all. And you'll be able to find the
status of that device inside of device
manager. You can find that device driver
listed in this large list of devices.
And you can choose to remove, replace,
or roll back to a previous driver
version. Or when you log into Windows,
you'll get a message on your screen that
says one or more services failed to
start. Those services are obviously the
background processes that are running
inside of your Windows operating system.
And often they're not starting due to an
incorrect driver, a bad configuration,
or bad hardware itself. You can go into
the services app inside of Windows and
try starting the service manually to see
if you can get it running. If it's still
having problems, you might want to check
the account permissions. Many services
run as the system account, but some
services require additional
authentication. Sometimes these services
will have dependencies, so one service
has to start first, and only after that
service has started will the next
service be able to run. There's a list
of these dependencies inside of each
service profile. If this is a service
that is built into Windows, you'll want
to check the system files and perhaps
run sfc to confirm that your base
operating system is still configured
properly. If this service is based on an
application, you might want to uninstall
the application and then try
reinstalling with administrator rights
and permissions.
Sometimes it's the application itself
that is simply not running inside of our
Windows operating system. This might be
a message on the screen that provides
detailed information about what the
error might be. Or you may try to simply
start the application. The window might
appear and then instantly the windows
disappears with no error message at all.
Often the information about what just
happened on the screen can be found
inside of your event viewer. This is a
log that shows everything about what's
happening inside of Windows. So you may
need to filter down for that application
to find it in this very large hay stack
of log data. Windows also includes a
nifty utility known as reliability
monitor that tracks the performance of
your applications. And if an application
fails, it will identify what the failure
was. And you can easily click on this
screen to filter out all of the
information in your event viewer. This
can also be a useful tool to track how
an application has been performing over
time. You can see if this issue was
simply a one-off problem, or you can see
if the application has consistently been
having problems over a period of time.
If you think the application itself is a
problem, you may just want to uninstall
the app and reinstall to see if that
fixes the issue.
All the work that happens on our
computer happens inside of the RAM
that's in our system. So, in order to
keep all of these applications running,
we have to make sure that we have plenty
of memory available for them to work. If
we start running out of memory
resources, we might get a message on the
screen that says, "Your computer is low
on memory. To restore enough memory for
programs to work correctly, save your
files and then close or restart all open
programs." To know where to start, you
might want to go back to your task
manager and look at the memory column to
see how much memory is being used by
each individual application. You can
also sort this column by clicking on the
top, and that will bring the most used
resources to the top of this list.
Windows also has the ability to take
some information that's in your memory
and page it out to your storage drive
temporarily. This frees up room for
other applications to be able to work.
And when you need that information again
in memory, Windows will pull it off of
your storage device and begin running it
in the memory of your system. We refer
to this process as using virtual memory.
We're swapping out our applications and
putting them into a temporary storage
location. To find out how your virtual
memory may be configured, you can find
this under your system about advanced
system settings under performance
settings and virtual memory. On my
system, the virtual memory setting shows
that a paging file is being used and
it's using approximately 1,280
megabytes to store virtual memory. If
you wanted to change this amount or you
wanted to disable virtual memory, you
can do all of that under the performance
options.
The USB interfaces on our computers have
practically become the default
connectivity for most hardware devices
that are external to our computer. And
each time you plug in one of these USB
devices, they take up additional
resources inside of your computer known
as USB endpoints. The USB controller
that's inside of your computer supports
a certain number of endpoints. So your
USB controller might support 96
endpoints or 254 endpoints. And each
device that you're plugging in will use
a different number of endpoints. If it's
a more complex device, it will use a
larger number of endpoints. If you run
out of these endpoints, then you'll get
a message on your screen that says the
USB controller resources are exceeded
and the controller does not have enough
resources for this device. One of the
challenges in trying to troubleshoot
this is that it's hard to tell how many
endpoints is needed by each device that
you're connecting to your computer. If
you are receiving a message that says
the USB controller resources are
exceeded, you might want to try
disconnecting that USB device and
plugging it into a different USB
interface. Different USB controllers
inside of your computer may support a
different number of USB endpoints. So,
when you unplug from one interface and
plug into another, you might be
connecting to a different controller and
you might have more resources to use.
You might also find that controllers
supporting newer versions of USB may
have additional endpoints available. So,
you might want to focus on plugging USB
2.0 devices into USB 2.0 controllers and
plugging in newer USB 3 devices into
interfaces supported by USB 3.0
controllers. This would distribute the
endpoints differently on your computer
and perhaps free up the proper number of
resources for all of your hardware to be
able to work.
One of the most challenging problems to
troubleshoot is one that happens
randomly. There's no message. There's no
warning. The problem simply occurs and
you don't have any idea what may have
caused the problem to begin with. This
could be a software problem with an
application. It could be that the system
simply stops with no error message at
all. Or it might be a constant
application failure that provides you
with no feedback as to what might be
occurring. A good place to start would
be a full hardware diagnostic to confirm
that the platform that we're using is
working as expected. This would cover
your CPU, your memory, and all critical
hardware inside of that system. Most
motherboard manufacturers have hardware
diagnostics that are specific to that
hardware. Or you might find that the
UEFI BIOS inside of your system has a
hardware troubleshooting and diagnostics
feature built into the BIOS. Windows
also includes a memory diagnostic tool
inside of Windows itself. So you might
want to run that overnight just to
confirm that the RAM inside of your
system is working as expected. And you
might want to be sure that nothing has
modified your operating system. So you
might want to run the system file
checker or SFC to confirm that your core
operating system files are still valid.
And you might want to perform an
anti-malware scan just to be sure that
nothing unusual is running inside of
your operating system.
If you use Windows at work, then you
probably have found that you can move
from one computer to another, and all of
your configuration settings move each
time you authenticate to that device.
Windows refers to this as a roaming user
profile, and it makes it very easy to
have a consistent user interface and
work environment regardless of what
computer you're using. However, this
roaming profile has to download to each
computer that you're logging into. And
you may find in some cases that it's
taking an excessive amount of time to
log into your system once you provided a
username and a password. This is often
related to network latency between your
device and the domain controller that's
responsible for providing that
synchronization. Sometimes you're at a
remote site and it has to transfer that
information over a wide area network and
that wide area network might be
congested. or it could be that your
local domain controller is not working
properly and it has to go outside of
your local network to perform that file
transfer. This is often an issue that
can be resolved by your local Windows
domain administrator and they might find
that they're able to repair your local
domain controller so that now your
profiles will load much faster at that
remote location.
Our computers were not designed to be
great timekeepers. And if there was no
synchronization of the times on your
computer, you will find that it will
slowly drift away from an accurate time
frame in a relatively short period. We
can certainly fix this issue by
redesigning the internals of how each
computer manages the process of keeping
time. That is certainly not an easy
thing to engineer and it may require
additional cost to every system if we
were to integrate a better timekeeping
process. The fix here is not to change
the way that our computers keep time,
but instead change how often they check
to see if they are using the correct
time. You can set this with an automatic
time setting inside of your operating
system that will periodically go to a
central time server and update the time
so that all of your systems stay in
perfect time and date synchronization.
In Windows, you'll find this under the
settings app under time and language and
the option for date and time. When it
brings up that screen, you have the
option to set time automatically. This
is the default for most Windows
configurations, and you can even have it
adjust the daylight saving time
automatically if you happen to live in
an area that has that type of time
change. You can then set time zones
associated with that system and have it
synchronized manually if you'd like to
have the time updated immediately while
you're working on that system. This
ensures that this computer and all of
the computers on your network will all
be updated and synchronized with exactly
the right date and exactly the right
time.